welcome to exploring computing
today's video is bits bytes and binary
part one or it's all about zero and one
computers use the binary number system
so let's take a look at what binary
numbers look like we'll begin by
comparing
decimal numbers which are the numbers
we're used to to binary numbers
decimal numbers are based on the decimal
number system
which is the number system that you are
used to in the decimal number system
there are 10 different digits 0 through
9.
all the numbers that you're used to
seeing contain these
10 different digits we also sometimes
refer to this number system as base 10.
in contrast the computer uses a binary
number system
in the binary number system there are
only two
digits zero and one here are some
examples of the different types of
numbers that you can make with the
binary number system
we'll take a look in another video on
exactly how these work and what they
might mean
but for now just realize that all
numbers in the binary number system
consist of only two digits zero and one
and because of this because there are
only two digits we sometimes refer to
numbers using this number system as
being base 2.
what i want to look at next is why
computers use the binary number system
if we were to open up the computer and
look at computer memory what we would
discover is that
computer memories actually consists of a
whole bunch of different
individual electronic switches we can
think of these electronic switches as
being not that different than your
light switch and just as a light switch
on the wall can either be on or off
our switches inside the computer can be
on or off when the switch is
off we think of that as representing the
number zero and when the switch is on
we think of that as representing a one
so each of our switches corresponds to a
single digit
and since these digits can only be zero
or one they're binary digits and we
shorten binary digit to
bit so when you hear somebody talking
about a bit what they're talking about
is
a zero or a one or the memory inside the
computer which is being used to store
that zero or one
now we can't really do a whole lot with
a single bit
so we combine the bits together into
groups
and the main grouping for bits is a set
of eight
bits which is referred to as a byte the
byte is the primary measure of computer
storage
while i've been describing what happens
inside the main computer memory
all computer data is ultimately stored
as bits and bytes
so there are a variety of different
mediums that we use
to store digital information and in each
case that digital media needs to be set
up to store zeros and ones or bits and
bytes
so an ssd drive which is what's inside
most of your
laptops stores information
basically using electronic switches very
similar to the ones we've described here
however if you've got a hard disk if you
open up the hard disk what you're going
to discover is that
there are individual sections on the
disk itself that are magnetically
polarized and depending on the polarity
if the polarity is in one direction it
will be considered a zero if the
polarity's in the opposite direction
will be considered a one
if we take a close look at a cd a dvd or
blu-ray what we're going to discover is
that
the consists of a number of different
sections which are either
what referred to as pits or lands
depending upon whether there's a
pit in that section of the disk or a
land in the section of the disk
ultimately what we're representing with
these pits and lands is zeros and ones
so again ultimately all information
used by the computer is going to be
storing these zeros and ones
or these bits and they'll be organized
into groups of eight called bytes
while our first video has been rather
short the other videos in this lecture
are much longer
in the next video we're going to take a
look at how binary numbers actually work